هو حدث متوقع وسط تاهب يحمل اقصى درجات
الحذر اعصار من الفئه العليا ضرب الارخبيل
الياباني على طول المحيط الهادئ وكارثه
كبرى دمرت المنازل وشلت الحركه واوقعت
قتلى ومصابين في اقل من ثلاثه ايام انه
اعصار نانمادول الاكثر عنفا في العام 2022
فماذا حدث
في الثالثه عشر من سبتمبر بدا ان انمادول
كعاصفه استوائيه فوق البحر جنوب اليابان
وفي اليوم نفسه وصل الى اليابسه قرب مدينه
كاجو شيما الواقعه بالجزيره كيوشو دعت
السلطات اليابانيه ملايين الاشخاص غرب
اليابان لاخلاء منازلهم واللجوء الى مراكز
الايواء مع تحذيرات عاليه الشده بشان
فيضانات وانهيارات
وانزلاقات ارضيه انه شهر سبتمبر وهو موسم
الاعاصير في اليابان حيث تشهد البلاد نحو
20 عاصفه استوائيه وهطولا مطريا غزيرا لكن
تحذير هيئه الارصاد الجويه اليابانيه هذه
المره حمل صبغه خاصه مفادها ان المنطقه
ستواجه عاصفه خطيره كان يوم 17 من سبتمبر
يوما مختلفا في جزيره كيوشو الجنوبيه عند
الساعه الواحده ظهرا رصد الاعصار فوق
جزيره ياكوشيما الصغيره
اقتلعت الرياح الاشجار وحطمت النوافذ
وتسببت في ارتفاع مستوى مياه الانهار التي
باتت تهدد بفيضانات
اظهرت لقطات فيديو محليا هيارات لاسطح
المباني واللوحات الاعلانيه فيما انقطعت
الكهرباء عن اكثر من 350 الف منزل فيما
قدم لا يقل عن عشرين الف شخص ليلتهم في
ملاجئ بمقاطعتي كاجوشيما وميازاكي في
كيوشيو استمر نانودول في التحرك نحو
الشمال الشرقي وتراجعت قوته مع وصوله الى
المحيط الهادئ في صباح يوم العشرين من
سبتمبر تسبب الاعصار والفيضانات
والانهيارات الارضيه الناجمه عنه في مقتل
اربعه اشخاص على الاقل فيما اصيب 114
اخرون فيما قدرت الخسائر في صناعه التامين
اليابانيه بنحو 120 مليار يوان
كانت هذه اول مره تتعامل فيها البلاد مع
تعليمات قانون الاغاثه من الكوارث الجديد
حيث تم التغطيه نفقات البلديات لانشاء
مراكز الاخلاء ما ادى الى حمايه العدد
الاكبر من السكان
صنفادول الذي تركز تاثيره في محافظه
ميازاكي بالفئه الرابعه او الخامسه واعتبر
ثاني اقوى الاعاصير التي ضربت البلاد منذ
اكثر من 70 عاما
[موسيقى]